hello everybody and welcome to let's
play Skyrim okay now I'm not gonna do
that ever again welcome to let's play
Skyrim this is a game I've wanted to get
away from horror games for a little bit
and this is a game that I've wanted to
really sink my teeth into again I've
played it before but I didn't get very
far
and I have no idea where I was in the
main storyline now I don't know I barely
got the first words I think so I want to
get into this game and this is like I've
always loved the Elder Scrolls series so
I'm hoping that this is gonna be a fun
entertaining let's play actually I know
it is because this game is gonna be
fantastic this game always had been also
I've got an assortment of mods I've
totally forgotten more month I've gotta
know I've downloaded some that I've
never played before so
I'm excited I haven't played in a long
time since it came out I was there for
the midnight release I bought it I was
like the only person who bought it for
PC in the entire store everyone else
xbox and ps3 how was the winner of
course while everyone else downloaded it
but I wanted a physical copy
skyy real
hello hello gorgeous
I think some of the mods like changed
made some changes to the Union while hey
me finally awake
hang on you were trying to cross the
border right uh-huh
one second whoa what's that I need to
get the what is it
let's do expert just to give me a
challenge let's see here I'm looking for
the ah there we go
subtitles here we go that's all I wanted
alright and we're good
saving go got right into that Imperial
ambush what a miss us I won that deep
over there damn you Stormcloaks Skyrim
was fine until you came along
aha Empire was nice and lazy yeah
whatever they hadn't been looking for
you stolen that horse have been halfway
to Hammerfell so he could have you there
you and me we shouldn't be here aha the
Stormcloaks the Empire wants ride we're
all brothers and sisters and vines now
yes the top back there I love their ass
what's wrong with him huh what's wrong
with you you're speaking to Oh Frick
Stormcloak the true High King aha
Ulfric the yarrow Windhelm oh you're the
leader of the rebellion that sounds
about right
captured you oh gods where are they
taking us just you guess know where
we're going but sovngarde awaits
it totally is bro nice acting there hey
what the village are you from horse
thief why do you care
on Nords last thoughts should be home
uh-huh
Rorick stead I'm I'm from Roarke stead
Roerig still not sure how many graphical
changes that me let's get this over once
I don't think many more I mean sky
Renoir in terrific akatosh Divine's
please help me ah shut up
help yourself general Tully is the
military government uh-huh and it looked
like the Thalmor are with him damn elves
damn and he had something to do with
this
sooo damn elves this is Helen ah I used
to be sweet on a girl from here
wonder if Fela they're still making that
mead with juniper berries why not
he's probably dead funny when I was a
boy
Imperial walls and towers used to make
me feel now they're gonna make you feel
so dead
inside the house
yes
why are we stopping why do you think why
do you think all right let's go so does
Santa Claus Ulfric Stormcloak y'all of
window it has been an honor yaar Aloha
Riverwood hello
come on get me hello care of Rorick
stead
Rory you can make it man you can do it
go man go you got it you got it you got
it you got it
Oh nice splits wait you there me step 4
okay who are you Who am I Who am I well
I'm the most
beefiest handsomest Argonian you've ever
seen in your entire life Oh
lag ere we go Argonian yes
yes oh yes red skin tone totally beefed
out man like austra p beefy so awesome
head mmm look pretty good the eyes
aren't right aren't where I want it
eyes need to be
vicious no not beady little add those
eyes we're good the color ah there we go
need the reptilian eyes brow type yeah
get more spikes in there I need hair not
feathers any spikes
where are my spikes good good not too
bad
bikes and extra spikes yes
ah so many spikes I love it I love it
okay name yes
finish and name i keratin yes nah-ha yes
are you a relative of one of the rift
and dock workers Argonian no captain
what should we do it's not on the list
so forget the list he goes to the block
fu captain if you do I'm sorry I don't
care I assure you of a main saw a turn
to black mom make you sure the remains
are isn't return to black mush or
something like that I don't know don't
judge me
I forgot how long this intro was all
Frick stormcaller some here in Helghan
call you a hero all right but a hero
doesn't use a power like the voice to
murder his king and usurp his throne
actually that seems exactly something
you started this war one Skyrim into
chaos and now the Empire is going to put
you down and restore the peace so why
wouldn't you have tried to execute him
first oh it's not so pretty
carry on yes yes general give them their
last rites miss [ __ ] [ __ ] as we
commend your souls to a serious
blessings of the eight Divine's upon for
the love of Talos shut up and let's get
if you had waited just a little bit
longer lost you and I could have
survived come on morning yeah
my ancestors are smiling at me Imperials
you say the same uh-huh at least this
guy goes down like a ball yeah that
sucks yeah but she said not what he said
no please don't do that house fearless
was the lizard oh I'm so killing you
[ __ ]
there it is again did you have that now
that's a lizard I said next prisoner to
the block no you said next wasn't easy
go easy just like your mama
yeah
I'm on and I'm gonna pick the other head
out of the box no I'm gonna do that it's
what do you see whatever you think it is
screw the townspeople fixed me
I'm up let's go let's go man let's go
screw you I'm going I'm up up the stairs
I know how to get through this I get a
cart I know he's gonna braggin somebody
that doesn't hurt not even a little bit
doodoo oh yeah baller let's go let's go
oh yeah you I don't care what's this Oh
a dragon doesn't scare me
haha yeah yep yeah I got business to
take care of elsewhere
DRA Gon's day me out of here
yeah I'm definitely not going with the
people that just try okie dokie ralof
Radloff real of ralof ray-ray laughs
either way go with the people who I
trust now with the people who wanted me
dead
thank you very much
come on escape Heligan brother looks
like we're the only ones who made it
probably that thing was a dragon no
doubt
just like the children's stories and the
legends uh-huh the harbingers of the end
time we better get moving
come here let me see if I can get those
bindings I'm already here you want me to
come closer man this is there you go you
may as well take gun yours okay will do
take off our stay go yes do this I'm
going bare fisted I saw a guide once a
video where this guy just went bare fist
of the entire time I would love write in
the comments if you want me to play the
entire game just no just punching
dragons to death there's a way you can
do it you get like gloves
the special gloves I get plus dawn arm
disenchant give me a chance
comer I'm not hiding [ __ ] you seven
scratch your eyes out [ __ ] come here
come here
where you running are you running off
see ya oh wait in the nares
ya see that see that [ __ ] all of that
and I need to quit some armor not the
light stuff let me get the heavy stuff
oh that's what I'm talking see shut up
yeah give me a heavy armor that was
another part of it you had to have like
heavy armor gloves to get the full
effect from some skill here we are on
the key let's see if it opens that door
and to does not block I'm sorry we're
all off rail off oh yeah yeah so ready
bring it on yeah I guess you can't block
with your fists that's okay I don't need
to block with my fists our heads uh-huh
yeah okay let's go
so wait a sprint definitely forgotten oh
yeah potions traders don't care don't
care you gonna suffer worse right now ah
get out of here or get over here get to
the right I'm gonna scratch your friggin
eyes out
get over here yeah until I get the
rights to do a wheel
[Music]
give me all that ah spider that's a
spider yes yes I'm done are you done
let's keep moving to fit the BC Argonian
that I am where is he
I can't even tell two-handed weapon I
need a two-hander shut up might need
that gold okay if I remember how to ruin
this there we go there we go okay I'm
not an it let's go and this guy shrubs
bark sorry
stripped you naked how about that yeah
okay alright that's actually all the
time I got for this episode thank you
guys so much for watching I hope you're
gonna like this let's play because I
love this game and I want to get I want
to get far I barely to scratch the
surface in the game I mean I've the time
I played I spent so much time doing like
just bounties in side quests and I never
got into the game anyway thank you
everyone so much for watching and as
always I'll see you in the next part
bye bye